Cobra Kai's third season is full of tension
and surprises.
Kreese takes over Cobra Kai with "no mercy,"
Daniel and Johnny team up, and all three sensei
confront their pasts as they prepare to settle
their present-day differences.
Let's break down the explosive ending, and
what it may mean for season four.
After Robby makes Miyagi-Do infamous for what
happened during the school melee in season
2, Daniel finds that his karate-themed advertisements
aren't so cute anymore, as his car sales begin
to drag.
His top competitor, Tom Cole, secures an exclusive
distribution deal with Doyona and offers to
buy Daniel's dealership at a bargain price.
But Daniel decides to take a trip to Japan
instead.
After an inauspicious meeting with Doyona,
Daniel visits Mr. Miyagi's home in Okinawa
and reunites with Kumiko, the young woman
he defended and had a romantic relationship
with in The Karate Kid Part II.
Kumiko has several surprises in store for
Daniel at Tomi village, including Mr. Miyagi's
old love letters to her late aunt Yukie and
a visit from the now-grown woman he rescued
from a typhoon as a child.
She's now VP of international sales at Doyona,
and as a long overdue reward for saving her
life so many years before, she steps in to
save his business relationship with the company.
Not only does the LaRusso Auto Group come
out of their PR nightmare relatively unscathed
in the end, but they also convince Anoush
to return to their team, and find that cousin
Louie is actually a pretty solid salesman.
With the dealership on solid ground once again,
Daniel will be able to focus on his more personal
matters going forward.
Another familiar face Kumiko brings back into
the picture is that of Chozen, who Daniel
defeated in a brutal fight in The Karate Kid
Part II.
Rather than holding a grudge, however, Chozen
wants to make amends.
Chozen reveals that his sensei Sato was also
trained by Miyagi's teacher, so he has inherited
several artifacts from Miyagi's dojo and wants
to test whether Miyagi really taught Daniel
everything he knew.
During a match, Chozen stuns Daniel by striking
several pressure points and disabling his
limbs, a maneuver he attributes to Miyagi's
teachings.
After pinning Daniel, Chozen ends the fight
by honking his nose, which is a playful nod
to how Daniel ended their vicious bout so
many years before.
Chozen admits he has felt shame for his behavior
back then and is relieved to learn that Daniel
has forgiven him.
In return, Chozen agrees to train Daniel in
Miyagi's powerful move and also gives him
a cherished scroll from Miyagi's collection
to take home.
Not only does Daniel walk away with a newfound
peace agreement with Chozen, he's also armed
with a very effective new defense technique.
"If only every rivalry could end like this."
In addition to saving his business and learning
a new trick in Japan, Daniel also gets some
closure with Kumiko.
Though the two had an intense connection in
Okinawa all those decades ago, they lost touch
with one another and moved on with their lives.
The two lament the fact that they might have
kept in contact more easily in the modern
era of social media, but they part on great
terms.
Kumiko isn't the only ex that Daniel gets
to finally say goodbye to, either.
Ali also returns to the picture after she
and Johnny reconnect on Facebook.
Though Johnny has finally begun a romantic
relationship with Miguel's mom Carmen, he
can't resist the chance to catch up with his
high school flame.
The two spend a whole day together having
fun at lunch and an arcade, and she takes
him to a country club party that Daniel also
attends.
“You remember Johnny Lawrence, right?"
"How can I forget?"
Ali is bemused to find her former flames fighting
just like old times but correctly calls them
out for being more alike than they'd like
to admit.
She also accepts Daniel's apology for ending
things so abruptly and thanks Johnny for making
her feel young again before wishing him well
with Carmen.
The memory of fighting over Ali has always
been a point of contention for Daniel and
Johnny, but now that the two have gotten a
chance to talk things out with her, they can
finally let go of that piece of their animosity.
"And the truth is, you guys are more alike
than you want to admit."
Johnny and Carmen aren't the only new lovebirds
taking flight this season.
It looks like Miguel and Sam are also ready
to octopi some space together again, too.
After training with Johnny, Miguel is back
in fighting shape and returns to school.
Sam apologizes to Miguel, helps raise money
for his treatments, and even shows him around
Miyagi-Do.
The sight of them together might make Robby
incensed, and it even raises eyebrows with
Daniel, but Sam and Miguel share more than
just some smooches.
Together, they hatch a plan to unite their
dojos for the greater good.
Meanwhile, Demetri and Yasmin have become
unlikely kissing buddies -- not that she'd
ever admit that in public, of course -- and
something is definitely brewing between Robby
and Tory.
After Robby is released from juvenile detention,
he and Tory bond over their equally crummy
upbringings and their mutual dissatisfaction
with the idea of Miguel and Sam getting back
together.
Whether these two will combine their anger
to form a butt-kicking power couple remains
to be seen, but based on the looks they give
each other in the final episodes, we wouldn't
be surprised if their relationship is about
to heat up off the mat.
At first, Miguel has trouble convincing the
members of Johnny's new Eagle Fang dojo to
join forces with Sam's Miyagi-Do members.
But once the Cobra Kais attack them all at
their Christmas party, the battle lines are
officially drawn.
This means former besties-turned-rivals Mitch
and Chris and Bert and Nathaniel can finally
fight together again, instead of forcing themselves
to hate each other.
Perhaps the most surprising member to join
this new team is Hawk.
He is initially poised to be Cobra Kai's new
champion and takes Kreese's tough teachings
to heart, even breaking Demetri's arm during
an off-the-mat confrontation.
All season long, though, Hawk watches with
disdain as Kreese recruits most of his least
favorite people to join the dojo, including
his former bully Kyler and Robby, who Hawk
still blames for what happened to Miguel.
"Look, I know some of these guys, and they're,"
"Natural athletes, which is exactly what's
been missing in our dojo."
Hawk participates in the siege on Miyagi-Do,
but upon seeing his teammates attacking his
former friends, he decides to switch sides
and defends Demetri against having his arm
broken again.
He takes Demetri's side at Miyagi-Do for the
first day of dual training with Eagle Fang,
making it clear that these two are finally
ready to fight side by side after so much
turmoil.
After the Cobra Kais attack the unsuspecting
kids at Miyagi-Do, Johnny decides to confront
his former sensei once and for all.
He's surprised to find his son Robby at the
dojo rising to Kreese's defense, but Johnny
still engages Kreese in a fight that very
nearly turns deadly.
Robby discourages Johnny from using a sai
on Kreese after he gains the upper hand, and
Kreese makes him pay for that moment of mercy.
After Robby himself tries to pick a fight
with Johnny, Johnny accidentally knocks him
out against a locker, and Kreese nearly chokes
Johnny to death.
However, Daniel arrives in the nick of time
and kicks Kreese off of Johnny.
After a brief fight, Daniel uses Miyagi's
disabling move to stop Kreese in his tracks.
Kreese suggests that instead of this turning
into a deathmatch, they finish the fight by
entering their students in the All Valley
Tournament they all stood up to save.
If Cobra Kai loses, Kreese promises to disappear
from town for good.
While Johnny and Daniel unite to take Kreese
down, however, Kreese maintains one last trick
up his sleeve.
Throughout Cobra Kai season three, we finally
learn why Kreese is so hellbent on his "strike
first" and "no mercy" philosophies.
After enduring the death of his mother and
bullying in his workplace, young Kreese finally
fought back when one of his tormentors hit
his girlfriend, Betsy, who then became Kreese's
girlfriend.
He signed up for a tour in Vietnam shortly
after, and was recruited for a covert mission
alongside his friends Ponytail and Twig.
Tragically, the entire unit was captured on
that mission.
Ponytail was immediately executed, while the
others were made to fight one another to the
death above a pit of snakes.
Kreese's captain, who regularly accused him
of cowardice, was chosen to fight Twig, and
Kreese volunteered to take Twig's place.
The captain nearly defeated Kreese after he
revealed Beth had died in a car accident,
but Kreese gained the upper hand.
Even as they were saved by air support, Kreese
kicked the captain into the pit and declared
he'd finally learned his lesson: Show no mercy.
Twig, who may not have seen Kreese kick the
captain, told Kreese that he owed him a life
debt and would always be there for whatever
Kreese needed.
Now, it appears Kreese is finally ready to
collect.
After Kreese makes his deal with Johnny and
Daniel to settle their disputes at the tournament,
he makes a call to an old friend while holding
a photo of himself with Ponytail and Twig.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.